également chaque corporation
lamy
les
formation rémunération
maintenant il a préféré parler de
l'après par personne
aujourd'hui
la naissance
facile d'être président du jury c'est à
dire d'un côté de l'avarié
est-ce que c'est plus j'allais dire
méritoire d'être de l'autre côté
lorsqu'on attend ils ont cruellement une
récompense cet état de shannan je pense
que c est que les gens très gentils
moi je suis très surpris d'être un
président et des choses mon dieu ce qui
me sont arrivés enfin cette année alors
je suis encore éclaté très début mais ça
consiste en quoi être président de cette
flexibilité mais vous dire après si vite
et je pense qu'ils vont se terminer tout
seul les gens s'arrêtent quand c'est là
l'un est il là ils vont chez tout être
sacré de remettre le prix du meilleur
atout important
ah oui c'est très comblé c'est important
non non non je lui dis pas ça mais c'est
une occasion joyeuse et pas seulement
bédié au trac il a d'ailleurs nous
allons vous montrer les l'égalité qui
sont arrivés tout à l'heure puisque
maintenant ils sont presque tous en
salle et vous allez voir que pour la
cauvery rue d'affaiblissement de
d'entrée avec ses crimes
luz
dominique sanda qui va mettre un point
final aux soldats y est elle est là pour
remettre un prix
et puis elle tout à fait le film le
grand bleu qu'il ya des nominations
les ministres auditionnés la culture
marisa berenson qui va remettre un prix
dominique lavanant
nous n'avons pas facilement du les
ignorer a tancé la mutation tanner
les lauréats soit pour le grand prix
donc pour l'ours de jean jacques annaud
ensuite pour les michele dean il écrit
pour le grand bleu luc besson un bond du
non pas dans les grands prix nous avons
également une demie le pack là où je ne
vais pas vous y fier à des acteurs et
des actrices comme jean paul belmondo
daniel auteuil sera favori jean paul
belmondo itinéraire d'un enfant gâté
vous avez refusé le prix parce qu'ils
considèrent que sont meilleures
conditions le public et de placer ce
genre de récompense libre alvin khalid
l'affréteur vignes en tout cas merci
merci ttrs notre maîtrise elle donne
rendez-vous dans quelques instants dont
deux en quelques minutes pour cette nuit
des césars en direct sur antenne 2 voilà
juste avant de vous quitter je vais vous
donner les résultats du tiercé du
quartier où s'est couru cette atonie dit
vous allez voir les résulats s'inscrire
écran pour gagner le gers il est allé
jouer le 3e et 2007
ça rapporte de 1344 ans et pour ce qui
concerne le quartier que vous allez voir
tout de suite installé derrière nous a
ajouté le 5 et vous gagnez un peu plus
de ram il sera donc après ce journal les
prévisions météo la nuit des césars donc
sur notre chaîne puis gaccio pour les
toutes dernières informations
et puis moi je vous donne rendez vous
abonnant à 13h bonne soirée à tous